you
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for Chapter one of our four part
series on transforming healthcare into
health creation today's presentation is
titled chapter one what is health
creation presented by Jeremy Schubert
divisional vice president USO commercial
operations of Alba Diagnostics and Brian
Clark director of operations at GC
LabTech I'm Christie jewel of lab rats
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminars
brought to you by laborat and sponsored
by Abbott Diagnostics for more
information on our sponsor please click
on the Abbott logo at the left side of
your screen now let's get started I
would like to remind everybody that
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab down at the top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem by using that ask a
question box today's presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I would now like to
introduce to you today's speakers
Jeremy Schubert divisional vice
president USL commercial operations and
Abba Diagnostics and also joining us
today is Bryan Clark director of
operations at G C lab tech for complete
biographies on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen gentlemen you may now begin your
presentation thanks Christy ladies and
gentleman this is Jeremy Schubert as
Christy said I'm the divisional vice
president for core lab operations for
avid Diagnostics but I'm here today to
present to you not as the leader of our
core lab business but I'm here to
present to you today as a public health
official I said it to walk through
really where the future of healthcare is
headed and to try to help us all
understand think about and anticipate
the role that we can play as individuals
and as a lab community to contribute to
the success of the evolution of a
healthcare environment to contribute to
the Wellness and well-being of our
communities and to contribute to the
relevance of our profession and so
that's we're going to talk about today
and it's going to be bit of a pulp
fiction story what I mean by that is I'm
going to tell you a bunch of different
dynamics that don't seem to coordinate
or collate together but in the end I
promise you it all come together in a
nice clean story with good solid
outcomes and direction for how we can
proceed forward and I always like to
start this story with the story of
Stephen Elop if for those of you that
don't know Stephen was the CEO of Nokia
and I'm single-handedly keeping this
man's personal pain alive because of
what happened to Nokia now several years
ago if you were walking around the globe
particularly if you were in Europe you
couldn't swing a dead cat and not hit a
Nokia phone nokia was at the top of
their game as a business there wasn't
anyone that was even close and they were
they were they were supremely successful
and then all of a sudden the dynamics
changed ah Nokia and Nokia actually
doesn't exist today and you know in the
in the very emotional press conference
that Stephen had he uttered what is
perhaps the most profound business
statement since since the 2000s began
which is we didn't do anything wrong
but somehow we lost I think it's
important for all of us to really digest
that statement because you know for us
as we look forward into healthcare we
look forward to building the relevance
of the lab it's not about not doing
anything wrong it's about making sure we
understand what's the right next thing
what's the right evolution we need to
take what's the right change we need to
make how do we actually tweak who we are
and what we do and how we do it to
create everlasting and incremental value
and and that's a challenge for us all
and so as we start this conversation
it's about really putting ourselves on a
footing so that we can anticipate what
that looks like sounds like in his life
now this story actually has to start of
us wheeling way back to 2013 and the
interesting part about this and maybe
surprising to many on the phone was back
then medical error was the third leading
cause of death in the United States now
if you think about that that's pretty
shocking but if you're near in health
care
in the depths of healthcare you
understand that's probably not wrong and
so given that it was a signal to our US
healthcare system that we could do
better and although it's not the
fundamental catalyst it was one of the
catalysts that drove us to rethink what
does value-based care look like in the
US this information actually triggered a
chain of events that brought us a new
quality definition for healthcare and
and in this quality definition it starts
to expand out to the outcomes so
although it's still a fee-for-service
type in the economic environment there
was a lot more interest in energy and
focus put on the outcomes that the
healthcare system was meant to deliver
and so a ton of assessment that's going
around to think about hey mr. health
system this is what we expect from you
and there's going to be a financial
incentives or penalties for you not
achieving that so there's economic value
that's recognized by rethinking what
quality is from a healthcare perspective
now I share this with you is what you
don't see up here our lab metrics you
don't see turnaround time you don't see
cost per test you don't see specificity
and sensitivity of assets and it's not
that those things don't matter a high
quality lab cap accredited that that
counts right
but that's table stakes and so for us to
be relevant in the in the healthcare
arena what we have to think about and
challenge ourselves to think about is
how do we actually improve the CMS
metrics how do we participate and
actually are active and recognize for
moving the needle against these quality
domains that exist and so our story kind
of starts there of thinking about what
are the metrics beyond the lab that we
need to understand then we need to have
a meaningful plan for and active
participation in for us to be able to
drive and this is all a fancy way of
saying is the future of the lab is not
going to be identified by automation
alone I work for a company that has
automation and for sure automation is
important but automation isn't a central
theme of what the lab needs to be
in the future thinking about this
concept of the metrics that our health
systems are being abided by and what the
future metrics are going to be the
definition of the lab and the primary
responsibilities of the lab is to
improve the decision-making that happens
across a not just a patient pathway but
across the life course of an individual
it because it's these decisions good or
bad that modify the cost and the quality
of care that people receive this is a
great old axiom that 80% of the cost
cascades off the tip of a physician's
pen and that's just a fancy way of
saying the decisions that they make that
our physicians and clinicians make are
what going to drive cost and quality and
the lab actually is not you we didn't go
to school to learn to pipette by mouth
and we're not in the lab because we're
the best pipetters in the class we're in
there because our entire discipline is
centered around being able to take data
and convert it into insight that
improves the decision-making we're
actually at the coalface of what drives
cost and quality and we've got to
reimagine ourselves to be actually
taking responsibility in interaction
with how these discussions gets made
both within the health system and in the
normal life course of the individual so
what I'm going to do now is walk a
little bit about how healthcare is going
to change so I'm shifting gears a bit
and historically health systems have
been designed around this concept of
physical well-being it wasn't until the
90s that mental health became part of
the normal vernacular and really
featured more heavily and it hasn't been
till recently that mental health has
lost some of its stigma but that's
actually not the core definition of
health because the human has got
multiple domains in the mentions that we
care about
there's social health there's emotional
health there spiritual health I this is
a fancy way of saying we all want to be
treated holistically not just for our
physical condition and the concept we
have is you know who on this call wants
to be physically fit but emotionally
poor and if you have a hard time
answering that for yourself what
what you want for your kids now why I
share this with you is because the way
our culture is evolving is generation
the next level of generations are going
to want to be treated holistically and
so we have to understand that how are we
going to participate in a world where
this holistic element is important now
to kind of take juxtapose that against
something I'll give it kind of a quick
history lesson of health because most
health systems were designed around this
concept of cute care where we get sick
we go in we get better we leave it was
around 2010 although you know for many
decades this chronic you know care
element had been in the vernacular or
the research it was until about 2010
tell this chronic care revolution
started to take off where people started
to realize in talked so much about how
we have an aging population we have more
chronic disease and how that's going to
impact health care and how people
started to try to reshape around how do
I deliver I build a delivery system from
my chronic conditions and again although
it's been around for a long while in
terms of social research and in the
literature
it wasn't until actually 2014-2015 that
prevention really started to take off in
terms of how health care systems were
trying to reshape in really thinking
about okay if I can present prevent some
these conditions from happening
then you know I can I can have a much
better much more effective health system
and for those in the public health arena
you understand this is what we've all
known all along is that it's it's
insufficient to look through any one of
these lenses buy in to build a system
that's designed against any one of these
lenses well we have to be able to
consider is how do we take care of that
it can participate in the entire life
course of an individual right in
understanding how do you design a system
in such a way where you can each
individual can optimize their life
course against these concepts or broader
concepts of health and so what it brings
us to kind of the point of where
healthcare has to evolve because we're
no longer talking about healthcare
none of us are in that that business
anymore that business is a dinosaur that
does not exist anymore we're all in the
health creation business and so we have
to shift gears our thinking our
processes our models in such a way where
we can participate in a in a value
creating manner in health creation not
only health creation for individuals but
health creation for our communities and
health creation for our systems at large
and so health creation be kind of kind
of becomes the core in and so this is
kind of one dynamic of it's a different
endpoint in a much broader way of
thinking it opens up the possibilities
to create a ton of ton of economic and
clinical value now kind of taking that
one step further many of you might be
familiar with the social determinants of
health you know starting around 2018
this became again something that started
to surface more heavily in the u.s. than
fit in even globally around social
determinants and those and the impact
that they have on healthcare again
social determinants have been around for
a long while
whiteheads papers published in the 90s
so there's there's a ton of a kind of
runway to this but it hasn't been until
recently that you know we're starting to
wake up to recognize him as a health
systems we got to deal with this now for
those of you that are not familiar with
the concept the concept is simply that
10% of your of your of your health is
derived from the health care that you
receive there's so many other social
factors that come into play here some
that are obvious like do you smoke do
you live in a in a in a poverty area
some that might be really latent and
hard to tease out like do you come was
your father a blue-collar worker do you
come from a mixed family so there's a
ton of these other things that come into
play that do affect the overall
well-being of the person and why this is
important as we start to take it even
one step further is we can learn more
about a person's condition in their
health from their zip code than their
genetic code
and that's a very provocative statement
because if you think about where is all
of our investment at lab medicine going
where is the where's the cool new sexy
technology it's it's in this concept of
the omics right where we're trying to
understand and you know sequence genes
and do all the genetic testing and the
reality of life is there's a wealth of
information that might give us better
insight to that human to that person
from their zip code and it's about being
able to now you know think a little bit
bigger about how do we use that
information to facilitate better
productivity efficiency and
effectiveness of the system to provide
it that overall care the bottom
quadrants you see to the bottom right is
although it's difficult to read is it
gives you a flavor of the light blue
bars the spending that every country has
on health care and the dark blue bar is
the spending that they have on social
services right so handling these social
determinants if you will and although it
is a truism that the u.s. spends more
per capita on health care that light
blue bar that spike that you see and it
is a truism we spend less on social care
when you blend the two we're kind of
somewhere in the middle I don't share
this with you from a political statement
that says hey from US perspective we
should spend more on social care that's
not the point
even if we flipped our entire model and
doubled that investment it might be a
decade before we got to see the real
benefits of it in overall cost and
quality of life however what it is to
say is if we're in the health care
system as we know it today it's just a
call to attention that we're going to
have to deal with the social
determinants factors through the
healthcare system there's not sufficient
services and existing infrastructure
otherwise to handle them any other way
and so so we have to have awareness that
we got to build systems that are capable
of compensating for maybe a lack of the
social departments for for the for in
general no other mechanism for us to
solve through them so that's just more
that now as it relates to kind of some
other factors to consider as we think
about the future of healthcare you know
we talk a lot about personalization
personal
CAIR personalized medicine but the real
word that we should focus on is
engagement is how do we engage with the
person because we can personalize a plan
to any single individual I myself have
had a number of personalized diets that
people have given me their personalized
for me that's not stopping me from
eating donuts unless I engage with the
diet versus the donuts I have I'm not
going to have a better outcome and so
for all of this is just to say we have
to have this sense about how do we
create engagement and interaction with
the people that we're trying to serve in
addition to that we have to understand
that people want their health care
integrated into their day-to-day life
it's insufficient to have the health
system be defined as four walls of brick
and mortar that people want to
experience that in their day to day life
and they will the the dynamics will
change to enable people to do that let
me give you the kind of core example of
this is yesterday you know there are
smart toilets they can they can do a ton
of diagnostic type testing there are
mirrors that can tell if you're anemic
if you're upset if you haven't slept
many of you have a smart watch and a
smart bed that can tell you how long you
slept how many times you stirred how
many breaths you took how many
heartbeats you have a ton of information
but as you move that further there are
smart fridges that can tell you how many
calories you withdrew and what type of
food that you're eating Siri can tell if
you're upset our Alexa can tell if you
if you're sad or you've been working
late it's not unrealistic to consider a
world where you walk into the morning
after morning routine to get a cup of
coffee and for your refrigerator to tell
you to put the donuts back in the fridge
and take out the tofu and for Alexa to
come over and said hey I noticed you've
been working late you're not sleeping
you sound really depressed I've ordered
you some Prozac
the drone just dropped it off on the
front porch I sent a Roomba to pick it
up so this is not an unrealistic outcome
and so why I share that story with you
is the location of care the location of
Diagnostics the the engines that may
drive that direction of care may not be
and probably won't be the traditional
lens that we look at so in that world we
have to be preparing for how do we
participate and continue to create value
to do that now a couple of interesting
barriers and opportunities all
ecosystems have these three primary
components the health system as we know
it today the community resources whether
that be food pantries social services a
ton of other things and then at home
which I would say it's just your general
life course day to day work it's a
challenge that we have in most health
systems or in most communities as these
things are not connected at all they're
not connected at all and what we want is
a world where there's there's a
connectivity across all of these things
so it really is fully integrated into a
person's life but they do have access to
health resources health system resources
that are beneficial but that those can
be coordinated with community resources
that are beneficial and those can be
integrated into the day to day life
course of the individual that being said
you know we want to think about the
endgame of this is healthcare is like
Wi-Fi it's not defined health creation
is like Wi-Fi it's not defined by
borders and brick and mortar it's kind
of integrated in surrounding a
population and this is effectively where
it's headed now the challenge in the
opportunity exists and one simple thing
is because it's not that all these
capabilities these resources don't exist
in fact we actually have sufficient
amount of resources to do to create a
ton of healthy living for people a ton
of quality life years for people however
the challenge is that the sit these
entities can't communicate data can't
move and therefore it can't be used as
effectively as it needs to be these
bridges between external data into the
health system even bridges about moving
data to the right places in health
systems bridges out to the community to
the home they're not viable today
however right we have to think about is
this
important for us to be thinking about a
world where these bridges exist now we
participate in as many cases from a lab
perspective we may need to take the
responsibility to build those bridges on
our own and using various technologies
that can help us get started some
additional backdrop to that an interest
of time is the fact that you know most
health systems are hitting some very
tough economic times a most are on a
glide path to minus 4% net income which
is just a fancy way of saying of not
being able to make payroll and shutting
down and this is a real problem and a
real challenge that the executives of
health systems are facing this is why
they get enticed to outsource and to
take a big check from one of the big
reference labs to outsource their lab
because from an economics perspective it
gives them some short-run relief over
short-run pain so there's an economic
driver to this that is really really
important for all of us to consider if
we're going to think about the future
role we have because from a laboratory
perspective it's not enough to say we
generate 75% of the clinical information
that's used in diagnosis whether you
believe that fact or not because it
really doesn't matter because 100
percent of orange juice comes from
oranges but that doesn't mean oranges
aren't a commodity so we really have to
think about challenge ourselves how
we're going to participate in creating
new value now what you might not know
right is today the lab is usually the
second or third best highest contributor
to the profitability of a healthcare
system so even once they're on this
glide path the minus three the lab is
the one thing that's probably profitable
for them it's the one thing that is
making the money now because of how
accounting is done in healthcare this is
invisible to most executives you may
think your executive knows this they do
not it is not that clear to them that
actually the lab is generating a ton of
activity-based value to their health
system and if you wanted to see this
information for your individual site on
the left if you let an average person
though they can give pull this
information for you and give it to you
the thing I want to highlight though as
we move to the future is that if you
think about it
from a Health System executive
perspective the person who's having to
navigate this minus three percent and
they want to do it through a combination
of growth and cost containment there's
the swim the primary swim lanes that
they would look at the EC on the right
hand side of slides are all things the
lab can impact it's not a stretch to
believe the lab can impact somebody's
net income by five to seven percent by
just reimagining what it does today
not by retooling with seventy million
dollars of automation by rethinking its
processes retooling with a little bit of
informatics support but can actively and
dynamically contribute to recovery
of the health systems are on the glide
path they can move them to profitability
and that profitability as a concept of
no margin no mission so being able to
continue the mission and continue to
evolve and continue to have the capital
available to reshape the metal systems
the lab is the savior and today it's
treated as the cost center to be
outsourced when it's actually probably
the one department that can release a
ton of this pressure from a financial
perspective and create a ton of value
from a clinical perspective and that
being said at least to us to just serve
five business principles that we could
run through and I'm not going to run
through all these you can see them on
the screen but it all will hit them at
the end but five core things that any
lab should be considering building on so
that they're in the best position to
facilitate helping their health system
and I'll come back to these at the end
for now I want to turn it over to Brian
and Brian's going to walk us through you
know what he's doing in his laboratory
given this dynamics of change and how
he's taking steps forward to reimagine
what his system is and how they create
value and what that value is right
Thank You Jeremy I appreciate it looking
forward to discussing thou GC lab tech
has implemented certain solutions to
help ease some of these items you just
mentioned standby let me get my slides
ready to to go with that I'd like to
introduce GC lab tech this is a company
that most people have probably never
heard of because we were incorporated as
recently as 2016 as an international
subsidiary of GC Pharma out of South
Korea what we do here at GC lab tech is
we exclusively perform laboratory
testing on source plasma donations
meaning we only test the required tests
from plasma donors whose plasma is going
for further manufacturing so that does
not mean we are testing whole blood
donations or anything like that it's
strictly sourced plasma donations in
which that plasma will then be made into
vaccines protein solutions etc we
perform the testing on that and with
that in our very short operating history
we actually stood up GC lab techs within
just a little over a year for us to
activate the company and get everything
ready and during that time since then
we've also become cap accredited we've
had successful FDA inspections and we've
also been inspected and approved by the
Korean Ministry of Food and Drug Safety
which is South Korea's equivalent of the
Food and Drug Administration and along
with that we've had a variety of
supplier qualification audits performed
all very successfully and why does that
matter because one of the key things
that has been one of the shining stars
for our process has been an inventory
management system and so with that is
what I will be going into with this
just a brief background on myself I was
the very first company a very first
employee within our company and I was
selected to lead the creation of a new
lab testing source plasma donors our
enterprise chose to make versus bi
meaning we chose to make our own
laboratory service rather than continue
to contract it out once an organization
reaches a level of performance that
decision can become a business decision
as to what you want to do do you want to
continue sending that out of the
contract service or do you want to
control it within the house and the
decision was made and therefore I was
contacted to build this company and with
that use my experience of being a
retired laboratory officer from the US
Air Force and also prior to that I've
been in the whole blood industry at the
South Texas blood and tissue center and
also with the clinical side with Baptist
Health System San Antonio for a brief
sense
so just like each of you is I looked at
our audience most of you are coming from
a clinical setting our lab states the
same challenges that you face and what
were those challenges well we were
created entirely from concept what does
that mean
whenever I joined our layout was pretty
much drawn up on a on a bar napkin and
that's that's a cliche and it sounds
funny but it's really true when I first
had my first discussion as to building G
CLT we seriously met at a at a hotel bar
and had a discussion and kind of drew
out what we were expecting and with that
we started without any infrastructure we
had nothing to replicate I know many of
you have expanded your own labs or
joined an organization that has done
that and typically you have SOPs already
established within a system you have a
facilities team you have a variety of
resources that you're at your ability to
use however with GC lab tech we had
nothing we had myself and our CEO at the
time and that was it so we had to create
everything everything from real-estate
searches to proper suitability placing
the organization within the right City
location working with coding and all of
those necessary items to make sure that
we were operating not only within
business compliance but also we had to
establish what instruments we were going
to use we're doing donor testing I even
though its source plasma donor testing
we still had to work within the confines
of what was approved by the US FDA
we had to establish supply contracts all
of the negotiations associated with that
and then to build upon that one person
can't do it all so I had to build a team
of staffing and that also included
taking care of all of our regulatory
filings and all the necessary steps to
ensure we were performing within
compliance
along the way we did choose to partner
with Abbott when we did instrument
evaluations we learned about some of the
resources that Abbott had available in a
for a laboratory and one of the things
that that brought us to Abbott was the
ability for the Allen IQ inventory
management system and what it would do
because here's the thing no matter what
type of lab you run whether you run a
clinical lab in which you're do
performing diagnostic testing for
patient care whether you're doing a tox
lab whatever whatever type of lab you're
doing even if you're doing a veterinary
lab what's one of the key things we all
have in common and that is inventory it
doesn't matter how many staff you have
it does not matter how many locations
you have in order to run a successful
laboratory everyone is going to need
inventory and so most most places have
been very successful at the
tried-and-true method of paper
management of inventory however when we
learned of the ability to have an
automated supply management system we
were intrigued because as we go through
the slides a little bit in my laboratory
total staffing we currently have about
12 employees for a company performing
hundreds of thousands of donor testing
each year so we only have a dozen
employees and more than half of that is
administrative and quality assurance
staff
on that note as you can see Jeremy did
speak to a number of things of how
healthcare is being shaped and shifted
into the future well this is one of
those realities which is actually
available to us right now we were able
to use the IMS system for a variety of
reasons with our inventory even though
we don't have many avid instruments we
were able to use it to tag our inventory
and we were able to do that with non
Abbott products we're able to have
immediate inventory snapshots as to how
much inventory we have on hand we can
trigger it to when we need to order
supplies based on lead times and it
helps us manage everything everything in
order for us to manage this because
excuse me one of the things that also
helped us with this decision is by us
being able to monitor this workload
because we were unable to bring in a
bunch of staff because we wanted to use
automation at our fingertips and we knew
that we had gaps we wanted to not hire a
bunch of extra staff to manage things
that were could be automated and with
that what we wanted to do was even get
to a point where we could use that
decision those decisions to shape our
business without having to bring in
extra staffing in order to manage that
that it helped us address these
challenges well here's the thing is that
with this inventory management system as
I spoke about everybody has inventory no
matter what it is and we were no
exception our lab is very heavily
automated meaning that our
instrumentation does the work for us we
have pre and post analytic devices we
have instrumentation that takes care of
all the testing we have very few touch
points in our lab and therefore there's
with that level of automation there was
no sense in us trying to manage a paper
system of inventory management and
therefore we considered and implemented
the inventory management system we're
able to easily tag other vendors
products - in our catalogue it has been
heavily evaluated with our CAF
accreditation and also with our FDA
inspections that we've had and even our
supplier qualification audits in which
many of them were exposed to this system
for the first time and it was a one of
the best practices several different
audits that we had just because of the
fact that we were incorporating new
technology and making changes rather
than just talking about changes we
actually had implemented it and it was
very simple to do
so on that note
what we expect with
an IQ and Abbott moving forward we're
moving into an integrated platform in
which the entire system will not only
touch our inventory management system it
will actually touch all of our
instrument platforms and be able to help
us monitor our business make crucial
decisions about how we're moving forward
what to what to improve upon not just
from a metric standpoint but from a
granular level of how much are we
spending per test you know how much are
we really doing in a cost per test
environment this system will allow us to
get to that granular of level with
staffing hours from the ability to find
out how much we're truly inventory how
much we're bringing in an inventory how
much we're actually using we don't want
to have too little inventory and we
don't also want to have too much on the
Shelf being locked up with with
unavailable cost to be able to to make
use of so another item that is a really
great is that with this level of
in-depth analysis we're going to be able
to really make some good decisions and
we could potentially benefit our clients
by adjusting pricing in a more accurate
setting rather than just a an educated
guess
and so on this note I'd like to share a
little bit of our daily experience with
the IMS system I would like to preface
the video that this was taken within our
laboratory and as most of you know
laboratories are loud there's
refrigerators there's freezers running
instrumentation running to the normal
home of a lab is a present in our video
however I would like to just share a few
minutes of how we're using this system
to make our lives easier because again
it's really important to understand that
no matter what type of lab you're
running you have to handle inventory and
you have to be able to do it easily and
if if you remember I only have a few
staff members available and therefore
this system is taking the place of many
many staff members and with it with the
touch of a few scans and at our
fingertips we have ultimate control over
our entire laboratories inventory so
with that I would like to turn it over
to the video and please enjoy
you
in her the quantity
[Music]
once we've done that guidance in a
pharmacy area this automatically places
the items Department or any items such
as controls his or any other items in
qualifications prior trees are
automatically placed entities so as you
can see in just a few minutes very easy
to add in products and forests another
convenient feature in the app and I
invest this one is the ability to pull
pre-existing reports and also custom
Crystal Reports we use the system quite
extensively to monitor our supply levels
our expiration dates make sure we're
following accreditation standards and
also regulatory requirements but the
ability to have at your fingertips
information is what our inventory
statuses helps prevent shortages it also
helps prevent immediate shipping
requirements and get product to us we
just have a good visual on everything is
important related and with that we
probably use most commonly just a
overall inventory check we also use
various reports to monitor our usage
rates and also how quickly in the blood
group applies and we can even gauge the
lead time that it takes sometimes
forward products come in and so with
that this has been
people asked yeah but I am innocent the
ability to add that derivatives subject
our forces another frequently asked
question that we get at UT lab tech is
how easy was it to implement the
advertisements that first will describe
the implementation process it's quite
easy we can help from the Abba team
throughout the whole process building
the catalog was fight to but the
template that they sent the most
extensive harsh portion the process was
actually tagging and cataloging all the
slides into the system after that the
system has been extremely easy to use
and has saved us hundreds of man-hours
of time and receiving inventory and
keeping up cars but like with any
project it's easy to see that some
investment will be needed at the funded
project however the end result is
invaluable
it is been a system that has worked very
well for us
and not look forward to returning to the
paper system important in any way they
just consider it an investment time
upfront well worth it in the end
in closing the avid IMS systems been a
real game changer for our laboratory
we've been able to comply with all of
regulatory presentation standards eat
it's been a very good system we have had
zero instances of having to emergency or
urgent ship monitor supplies to is
perused because we've been able to
manage that inventory successfully also
our team has not used any expired
reagents accidentally because of the
digital foreign team
loudness control over those items far
greater than the human touch another
item is working in the laboratory for
over 20 years distance this is a
brand-new baby to do inventory and
laboratory management and any age any
other type of man it doesn't necessarily
have to be a laboratory it can be almost
any product or service that you're
trying to manage an infant for the
controls are at your fingertips and very
grateful for Abbott to have such
products available at affordable price
thanks Brian for for that that
presentation and to be honest with you I
don't know how you got George Clooney
and Brad Pitt to do the video for you
guys but they did a fantastic job
definitely an oscar-worthy performance
so if you could introduce me that would
be awesome
so get sue for my friends on the phone
they're still with us just to kind of
conclude you know tying this these
things out as we think about we talked
about four five steps that you know the
lab should be considering working their
way through to ensure that they're in a
position to contribute in this new world
and what Brian to share with you even
though it's inventory management kind of
a concept it's about finding these
hidden costs and these hidden
inefficiencies that freetime to enable
all of us to focus put our eyes outside
the four walls of the lab anything that
can enable us to move our eyes to some
more more of a value creating activity
the better off for us and so you know
not to belabor these things but they're
they're about challenging ourselves to
have a different business process
expanding our business model beyond
moving towards just a few processing
results and giving numbers for our
business model actually step into and
integrate with clinicians and help them
make those clinical decisions help them
understand the options that are
available to them from a pathway
perspective even being in a position to
recommend how that plays out or stepping
into the physicians that we're serving
in the community in helping with their
quality metrics now they're how they're
driving their business and how they're
serving their patients to maybe even
reagent reimagining some of the services
that you provide to payers or to the
people that derive healthcare from your
system whether that be you know
different different reports or
information that facilitates helping
people be healthy be their best selves
or their best lives establishing
adaptive operations is also really
essential this is where they where a lot
of what you know I was talking about and
a number of things can fit in oftentimes
when we go out for RFP or we're trying
to retool our lab we do that maybe once
every seven to eight years but by the
time that system gets on the ground if
we think about it
only from an automation instrumentation
perspective and even an initial
informatics architecture it's already
outdated before it actually gets up and
running and the central theme here is
how do you build a lab operation that's
adapted right that has it's designed in
such a way where you can scale up scale
down scale out scale sideways where you
can consistently build and think about
using data differently to optimize what
you're doing to care for your health
system to care for the people that
you're serving
obviously integrating the clinical care
is an important step as well as you know
building back to this concept of this
health creation competency and I want to
talk about that concept of competency a
little bit because across the board
competency is is something different
than skills for knowledge for data
competency is is about it is
transferable if you will it's more than
just you know that we think it's about
you know building a bunch of related
activities that are transferable across
we think an example we might have is we
have utilization management right so we
all are asked as laboratories to reduce
the amount of testing that we have and
we may focus in with a few reports on
cutting out redundant glucose testing or
unnecessary CBC or the random PSA that
might get get or disordered on a woman
but the reality of life is utilization
is a competency that transcends lab
testing and so it's about thinking about
how do you create optimal stewardship
across the continuum what are the
principles what's the thinking what are
the behaviors what are the systems what
are the processes that need to be put
into play that facilitate ensuring we've
got optimal utilization of the precious
resources that we have yes
utilization can be an activity yes it
can be a report yes it can be a program
but at its highest order it's a
competency it's a way of thinking it's a
way of living it's a way of operating
the business and so if we kind of you
know summarize this this down into some
things that we can and
should consider to be able to move
forward from a laboratory perspective we
shared these five steps we talked about
competencies the best thing you can do
as a starting point for this is do a
deep dive assessment of your own lab
write a really critical look at
evaluating you know if you even just
start with the diagnostic cycle
evaluating you know how well that's
getting executed and identify where
these opportunities to create
incremental value and where are maybe
some things that we're doing today that
are actually creating an efficiency or
waste outside the lab we have a system
that can can do that that you can you
can use if you're interested in having
somebody help you with an assessment we
have a tool that you can you can be used
to help you do that by the same token
then it moves into going through a
systemized approach for how do you build
a strategy right because you you can
have a strategy in your head but that's
pretty much useless what you have what
you need is a really written plan that
then is converted to some sort of
balanced scorecard that's converted to
some sort of business process that helps
you manage it and again the
encouragement here is take the time with
your staff to to build a very meaningful
strategy that aligns to the strategy of
the enterprise it enables you to clearly
speak to the c-suite about what you're
doing and how what you're doing is
contributing to the success and
achievement of not only the goals but of
the metrics that are associated with
their health system and what they deemed
to be important if you can't align what
you're doing day to day in the lab -
what's day-to-day important to the CEO
you're not going to be relevant to the
CEO and so we have a process that
enables you to do this but if you don't
you know what want to want to have you
know help from ours you know use some
process that enables you to get to a
written strategy a written balanced
scorecard in a modality or business
process of being able to consistently
communicate to the c-suite the value
that you're creating I'll end on a
personal story that I was asked to share
begin you because it's relevant to
you know tying all of this this often
importance that each of you have and in
transforming the healthcare system
because a you know I firmly believe in
the power of the lab several years ago
when I decided to go back to get my
master's in public health which no one
does there because you don't do that for
the money and for sure there's nothing
there's nothing you know cool about it
so when you go back to in the study
Public Health you got to have a really
detailed passionate reason why I went
back because I wanted to make sure I
wanted to ensure that I was able to
participate and whatever part of
healthcare was going to be the catalyst
for saving it for creating change for
creating value I thought that and I
thought that was somewhere besides two
laughs and after all the study and all
the papers and all the projects and
everything that you learned going
through that process I came to one
central conclusion there's no better
discipline to be a part of if you want
to change health care than the lab but I
have to kv8 that forward with two words
for now right now we have a as
laboratory ins as laboratory medicine
professionals we have an excellent
opportunity to be the catalyst for a ton
of value creation we can change the face
of our health systems by using our data
to anticipate what's happening with
disease burden with population shifts
and we can inform our health system of
what their strategy should be we have
the ability to improve the decisions
that clinicians are making by being able
to leverage our data and step into the
clinical pathway in an automated semi
automated or direct way to facilitate
these better decisions that they're
making and we have the capability and
it's the only discipline in a world
where that where people's health health
and health care going to be derived from
the home it's the only discipline that
can participate there and so in its the
bridge that can keep health systems
relevant in their communities and it's
important for now but we have to change
we have to we have to step in we have to
have a different business model we have
to have a strategy we have to understand
the you know the opportunities for
creating value for our health systems in
our communities we have to have measures
for that we have to have the tools that
enable us to participate in that we have
to insist upon it no one's going to
bring it to us we have to insist upon
that change in our health system because
that's what's going to make us relevant
for the future and with that my friends
want to thank you for your time and
we're going to turn it over Christy so
for any questions or comments to be my
one might have Thank You Jeremy and
thank you Brian for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
to an a portion of our webinar now to
our audience if any of you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask to a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we want answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started we have some great questions
already coming in now Brian laughs start
with you can we scan the packaging
barcode to build nan Abbott inventory
instead of manually typing in the
information hi Kristy thank you for the
question to address that yes it isn't an
option that we did explore we chose the
the typing option just for some of the
accuracy because sometimes it's just for
us it was easier to do it that way
however upon the implementation strategy
this could all be worked out with your
with your Abbott engineers when they
bring it in and you can get through with
that if you so choose but regardless of
whether it's typing or scanning either
option is very easy to do as you saw
with in the video that that took a
matter of seconds really and it's just
really simple for us to do so the
scanning option wasn't necessarily
something that we considered so
hopefully that helps answer your
questions
Thank You Bryan let's go with this
question for you as well how many
man-hours has the inventory solution
saved for your staff and have you
utilized that time any differently yes
another great question so with that if
you think about we brought this system
in relatively soon within our
organizations creative creation so we
were able to rather than calculate the
number of hours saved we were actually
able to use it in the sense that number
of positions saved because many of you
in your laboratories probably are having
several folks manage your inventory
meaning that you know depending on the
size of your facility most clinical labs
have everything broken out into sections
where the core lab or the hematology the
chemistry the microbiology area the
blood bank all kind of have different
supply you know managers if you will or
additional duties for us what I would
say is that this allowed us to not have
to worry about hiring more people to not
only do plasma testing but also manage
inventory and so forth we were able to
keep our costs very very minimal in
comparison to what it would take to hire
an additional employee or pay an
employee because in the laboratory
what's one of the main things that
generates revenue it's text performing
testing and turning out results and if
they're not turning out results
unfortunately they're not necessarily
generating revenues so therefore if you
look at it this is a lot this allows the
text to go back to the bench perform the
testing improve the turnaround times
manage the inventory and then as far as
utilizing that time differently I would
say from a managerial standpoint it
relieved a lot of worry and what that
means is that
I do not have to worry about my staff
using expired reagents I do not have to
worry about my staff having an urgent
supply order that has to be overnight
shipped to us and for those of you who
have that worry it's expensive it's
expensive emotionally it's expensive
economically and in order to utilize
that time differently I now have in my
lab a system that prevents me from
having to have that worry so for me it's
a it's a overall you know holistic
approach to utilizing time differently
because I don't have to worry about many
things that I once upon a time had to
worry about
Thank You Bryan now look so it looks
like we have time for a few more
questions I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer live today and those
that are submitted during the on-demand
period we addressed via the email
information you provided at the time of
registration okay Jeremy let's come over
to you now the labs perception within
the Health System is typically as a cost
center even though there is a lot of
untapped value
how can Abbot help change this
perception yes it's a good question for
those of you that don't know I'm from
Texas and I use kind of an in Texas
analogy here is you know the laboratory
medicine and as a discipline it'd be
analogous to you have this big patch of
Earth right that's sitting on top of a
hundred-year of oil reserves and you're
choosing the farm cotton on it and for
those of you that don't have a farming
background that's absolutely the worst
thing you can do with the earth for the
earth is the farm cotton and you've got
all this natural resource that sits here
and it's unfortunate because what most
executives see is a cotton farm right a
production facility that's pushing out
you know numbers on them on a daily
basis that's why I said where he ended
the presentation you know I first step
in that process that we can help with is
spending time working the assessment
really looking in 0ne on the diagnostic
cycle initially to identify where there
are opportunities to create value
economic and clinical and strategic that
matter to your executive right you know
turnaround time is interesting for them
but when you show them how they can
reduce length of stay by a half-day now
you're now you're talking more of their
language and so you've got to go through
an assessment process in a simplified
way be able to identify where the
opportunities are the second step is is
to really put together a meaningful
strategy and something that is is is
well thought-out
takes into context the health systems
objectives and the health systems
environment and aligns the lavs
activities in value creation mission
you support the health system because
again it's much more than turnaround
time and cost protests and so it's about
lining to some different metrics and
then being able to operationalize that
strategy that is the tough part for most
people and even most businesses because
you can have a lot of smart people
saying hey here's what we should do but
getting the behavior change in the
process change an infrastructure change
to make that happen is real the real
magic and so for that that's where you
said earlier is helping being able to
convert this strategy into some sort of
balanced scorecard that balanced
scorecard into some sort of business
process it has a routine way of driving
the tactics and the strategy a routine
way of assessing the data and in a
routine way of enabling the organization
of course correct but at the end of it
being tooled in such a way what I mean
the tools have the the informatics tools
available to you to be able to track
record your impact and more specifically
present back to the stakeholders that
matter whether it's the executive a
payer or a patient for a clinician
information that demonstrates how you
help them how you are helping them and
then enable them to engage with how you
can help them more and those are all
things that we've really rebuilt our
organization around assessment strategic
development business process
implementation supported by the
appropriate tooling to be able to
communicate engage with and drive value
through all full value through and for
all the stakeholders Thank You Jeremy
now before we wrap with Jeremy and Brian
do either of you have any final comments
for our audience
right
to go first Jeremy and Kristi thank you
real quick everyone I do appreciate the
opportunity to share how GC lab tech was
able to incorporate some some future
state technology into its present day
operations again you know not to not to
continue speaking about this point but
it is a fantastic tool that helps us
move into the future by no means do I
want to you know approve the point that
you're trying to reduce staff with this
new technology because it's not about
reducing staff it's really about better
utilizing your staff and this system
allows us to do that it's just one of
the many ways that the future of
healthcare and operations is upon us
and you know the Jeremy's right the
laboratory is a major driver and
innovation unfortunately we are just one
of the backgrounds within much of the
healthcare setting because for so long
many laboratorians have been a silent
partner within the healthcare system and
please use this opportunity to showcase
the innovation within your labs how
you're able to do things better even if
it's even if it's not to showcase
throughout your entire health system
just look at the tools around you find
the way to show that value being added
and I promise you your world will start
to change and really it comes down to
understanding how to communicate with
those who control your world you know
the c-suite the hospital leadership that
are often not laboratorians it's really
about trying to find the best way to
capture those opportunities to make
yourself relevant and so to emphasize
Germans point the lab it really is a
great innovator and it definitely has a
strong role in the health future of
healthcare so with that thank you I
appreciate the time today and
again look forward to another discussion
soon into it so just from my perspective
thanks Ryan from my perspective this
building out you know building off of
Brian's from you know points they give
you this too the first thing is I want
to affirm everybody on this call you
know that how important you are and
although I may not always be recognized
it's what was done every day and live
medicine is saving lives in is creating
value in health systems beyond what
anyone recognizes and the role you have
is extremely important and it can't be
overstated how important it is the
second point outside of affirmation is
encouragement I would encourage you to
really challenge yourselves your
thinking your team your institution to
reimagine the life to reimagine it not
as a production facility but reimagine
it as a decision engine as a quality
engine as a strategic engine and for
sure it means it has to do different
things so we have we have to feel we
have to feel empowered and encouraged to
actually build some new competencies to
approach our business differently and
it's all encourage you to really
challenge yourself to the degree of
uncomfortability about about doing that
and about stepping out and working with
clinicians and working with your
executive and bringing them some
meaningful meaningful help because I
promise you they will welcome it and the
research says that they will and I also
want to encourage you to reach out at
least at least to us I will tell you you
did you know that you there's a lot of
manufacturers out there but what we
would have want to provide or support
you is in that process not necessarily
the equipment for sure that's important
to us but I want to encourage you to
feel like you can reach out say hey I'd
like to have the profitability for my
institution we can get that for you
I'd like to have somebody help me with
an assessment we can do that for you so
don't feel don't hesitate to reach out
and ask for those things even if you
don't do business with us even if you
have no intention to do business with us
those are things were glad to to help
out with and so that's my last bit of
encouragement and final thing is thank
you thank you for your time and thank
you for your question and and we wish
you all the best in and being the
catalyst to change for health system and
thank you Jeremy and Bryan both for your
time today and your important
contribution into transforming
healthcare into health creation we'd
also like to thank lab rich and our
sponsor added diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
Mavericks will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be redirected to
the registration page for chapter two
redefining lab operational excellence
sign up now and you'll receive an email
informing you of the next live broadcast
we hope to see you there have a great
day